All right, hello everyone. How are you
guys doing? Hope you guys are having a
wonderful day. And today we are here
with another episode. This is episode
four of finding the best merches. What
we will be doing today is going ahead
and we will be merching the category of
herbs and herb seeds. So I'm going to
see how much money I can make in 1 hour
with 100 mil coins. As you guys can see,
this episode 100 mil isn't going to be
really that big of a deal. You could
definitely do this with way less, but
I'll be using it just, you know, because
it looks cool. That's about it. So let's
get on into this. If you guys want to
know what I will be using today, I will
be using GE Tracker to find kind of my
baseline margins and then I should be
buying one and selling one to the GE.
But if you guys want to check out GE
Tracker has some cool free features and
a lot of premium features that are
really helpful. You can check that out
in the description down below. But with
that being said, let's go ahead and
start this hour. So, let's do it. All
right, so the timer is started. Let's go
ahead and get this going. So, from what
I saw on GE Tracker, Quarmms look pretty
good right now. So, I'm going to check
out the clean and uh unclean versions
and see which one has a bigger margin on
them. All right, so as you guys can see
right here with the grimy quorums, I
actually have a decent margin, I
believe. Yeah, that's about 84 GP, which
should be pretty good. So, I'm going to
go ahead and try to buy I don't know
what the limit on these are. I know I'm
not going to be able to buy this many,
but uh if I have the cash and I have
barely any GE slots, I may as well fill
it up as much as I can. So, there we go.
going to buy some grimy quarmms and then
uh probably check out snapdragons and
raars I believe would be our next two
best bets. All right, now with rayonars
at least for the grimy and the clean I
probably will just end up merching them
even though they only have a 26 GP
margin because that's just like that's a
guar that's guaranteed money as there
are a ton of them that buy and sell in
hours. So it's definitely something I'm
going to want to go ahead and do. Now
I'm going to check out the regular RANS.
So 6 7 8 or 58. And as you guys can see
pretty much for the the clean ran arts
almost have the same margin. So I mean
together if all of those buy and sell we
should be making about 100k between
those seeds. So that's really good and
I'll take that. All right. So going to
go ahead and check out these Snapdragon
seeds now and uh see what we can get off
of these. So 300 or 30k and 600 GP and
we are able to sell it off for 30. So
that's about 450 GP, which is really
good for how many of these buy and sell
an hour. So I'm going to go ahead and
put in an offer for probably about 4 to
500 of them. I think actually I think
that the max you can buy is 199. So I'm
going to go ahead and do that then. As
you guys can see, the grimy ran are
almost done. So uh going to have to sell
them off here in a second. All right. So
as you guys can see, these uh the ran
seeds actually have a really good profit
about 800 GP on each one of those. So
I'm definitely going to go ahead and do
those. Going to check out torso now. All
right. So, the clean torso actually have
a 44GP margin, which I would say is
pretty good for them considering that
there's a decent amount of those bought
and sold cuz they're also a monster
drop. All right, GE Tracker also says
right now that torsal seeds have a
pretty decent margin. So, I'm going to
check those out. 31689, which is
actually really low for what this says
that they should be. So, I might just go
ahead and buy those and then end up
selling them off. I don't know how many
could be above that, but that's not too
bad at all. So,
31123 and we bought it for that.
However, I think we'll be able to sell
it for more to be honest. All right, so
as you guys can see, Snapdragon seeds
are almost already bought, which is
insane. All right, so let's go ahead and
check out what Toad Flex is. I know that
a lot of these are bought and sold, and
I guess we could check out the seeds
maybe as well. I don't know. All right,
so now going to go ahead and check out
some grimy Toad flex or probably
actually just regular Toad Flex, I
think. All right, so there we go. Got
all of our offers buying. For some
reason, a lot of Snapdragon sold, which
is a little scary because that's a lot
of seeds to kind of dump on someone. But
nonetheless, we got everything buying
right now. All of our ranars are also
done. I can merge more of them. However,
I'm going to go ahead and try and sell
them right now. All right, so going to
check out the price of RANS right now.
And as you can see, 6723. I was able to
kind of buy up the margin a little bit,
which is sometimes sketchy, but I went
ahead and did it considering I thought I
could do it, and it proved out to be
worth it. So, I'll be making 23GP off of
all of these, which in the end will get
me a little over 50K, which is really
nice. The Snapdragon seeds, we probably
should start selling off now, but I'm
going to wait for my GE limit to buy.
And then uh we are working with the rest
of these. We got a decent profit on all
of these. The ran our seeds is about 1k.
The quorums is a little bit. The uh ran
our weeds is about 30 40 GP. So it's not
looking too bad. And we got 52 minutes
left. So I think we can get a lot done.
All right. So there we go. All of these
snapdragon seeds are done. That was a
minute about or about a minute after
recording. So that's not too bad at all.
I'm going to see if I've hit my limit.
I'm pretty sure I have. So I don't know
if I'm going to be able to buy one.
That's a that's a problem that I have.
But uh yeah. There we go. So I've hit my
limit. I'm gonna go buy one on my other
account and uh yeah, we'll sell these
off. I just need to kind of get an idea
as to what they are. All right, so I
went ahead and bought one of the seeds
on my other account and they ended up
selling or buying for this price, which
means I would make no money as I think
that that is my own price. So, I'm not
going to go ahead and sell those off.
I'm going to actually risk and believe
that these things will raise since they
were just higher and kind of list them
up a little higher. So, off of this, we
will be making about 500 GP per one,
which isn't too bad. So, we should be
making about 100K if these all sell. But
that's a big if since uh I'm not really
sure. All right, something a little
weird here. Ran RC just kind of shot up.
Like I I wasn't buying any. So, I went
ahead and Insta sold one. As you guys
can see, I sold off for 24K, which is
pretty interesting. So, going to go
ahead and see what kind of margins there
are. Now, there's barely anything. So,
I'm going to see if I can continue to
sell these for pretty much med price.
And if so, then that's a good Yeah, I'll
take a I'll take a 15k profit off of
those few rand seeds I ended up getting.
All right. pretty early on kind of
questioning how good this could be
considering it just kind of takes up a
lot of space like if I had another
account which I do but I'm not going to
use for you know the purpose of the
episode and the series is uh you'd be
able to buy these and sell them off on
another account and kind of do that
quick with this I filled up my grand
exchange and uh we've kind of reached a
problem with it. So going to go ahead as
you guys can see over here I did
actually make or am going to
approximately make 50 to 60k on these
quorms for only having 268. That's huge.
They they have a huge margin right now
of 200 GP, but uh judging by someone
buying only one, I'd imagine they're
going to undercut me. Um as far as toad
flax go, we have a decent amount of
these coming in. And uh these are going
to have a decent margin as well. Like 80
80 GP or something like that. So that
should be pretty good. All right, dorsal
seeds are starting to just fall in on
me. So I'm going to go ahead and just
take out my offer on those before any
more accidentally come in that I don't
want to get. So going to go ahead and
see what price they will sell on for.
So, as you guys can see,
31.689. I ended up buying them all for
about 650GP less, which is really good.
However, I think that that's the med
price. And if I'm right, then I might
try to buy another one just to actually
make sure. So, that's not the med price,
actually. So, uh, we're going to try
31 689, right? Yeah. Okay. So, we are
going to go ahead and sell these off for
31689, which will mean that we should
get a decent what 500 GP profit off of
all these, which will give us a good
750K once they or 75K once they all
sell. I wish 750 I wish. But, uh, a lot
of Toad Flaxs coming in. So, I might
take out the Toad Flax offer and go and
see what we can make on these and try to
start selling them. All right, there we
go. So, 3125 for the Toad Flax. As you
guys can see, that's a good Jesus,
that's like 90 GP margins. That'd be
180k off of these if I was able to sell
it off for that. I don't know if I'm
going to be able to. However, these are
definitely going to be a good one if I
if I need to make some money for for
this video. So, there we go. Going to
sell those all off. I don't actually
need to make money for these videos. I
just like to get the highest margins and
just make the most money so I can show
you guys that you guys can make an
insane amount of money merching the most
random things. And if I come out with
like a 300k profit, it's like, yeah, I
could have killed green dragons for that
much. So, it's kind of useless. So,
right now, Toad Flax still have 124GP
margins. So, I'm definitely going to
take advantage of this and try to buy as
many of these as I can and then sell
them off at the end of the episode while
I go watch the Michigan Florida State
game. Um, as for the rest of this, the
quorums, I do not know what their margin
is anymore. I haven't had any buy in
forever and I don't think I've sold off
any other Yeah, I haven't sold off any
at all. So, I know that I have the
highest sell offer in. I believe we're
going to find out right now. So, I do
not have the highest sell offer in
anymore, which is a bit annoying, but uh
that well actually the highest sell
offer is me med. So, someone probably
just accidentally has someone selling
for med. And so, yeah, I don't I don't
know what we're going to do about that.
All right. So, I'm going to go ahead and
sell off these RAR weeds for 67
675. I'm going to go ahead and just
insta sell them so that I know I can
guaranteed sell them off instead of
having the prices fall on me. So 6775
and this should be a good two or about
30k profit. Well, it's only able to sell
off a few. So I'll up the profit or I'll
up the margin and we will get another 2
to 3k off of it in total. All right. I
think something I'm going to do to try
to help me sell off some of these herbs.
As you guys can see, I have a ton of
grimy ranar weed. The problem with this
is that like unclean herbs come into the
game at an extreme rate and they don't
sell because no one's going to insta buy
things that they're going to then clean.
So, I think what I'm going to do for
this scenario and maybe the quorums as
well is clean them while I'm waiting for
other things to merge. I think that's
the most effective way to do this. And
realistically, it would take forever to
sell these off and there's no way you
could expect it to sell even within
probably an hour to two hours. So, I'm
going to go ahead clean as many of these
as I can before the time limit while
also merging those as well. All right,
so there we go. Sorry if you guys can
hear anything in the background, but
some of the ranard weeds have sold off,
which is really good. Also, the torso
seeds have all sold, which is nice to
see. As far as the toad flags, we
haven't been able to sell off any, so
I'm going to lower that. But we have
been able to buy a little bit, which is
very helpful since those are really,
really inexpensive. The Snapdragon seeds
have ended up selling off, which is
good. And uh yeah, other than that, I
mean, we kind of got undercut in some of
the stuff, but that's fine. And I'm
going to go ahead and check the quorums
again. All right. So, at this time, it's
kind of looking like the quorums are
just going to end up selling off of the
med price. So, I didn't make a ton off
of them, but I'll go ahead and do that.
Now, I'm going to check the toad flaxes
to see how much we can make off of
these. These are kind of our big ticket
items as they have an insane margin
right now. As you guys can see, it kind
of dropped to 3080, which isn't too bad.
Still, we're going to make a lot of
money off of them, but we're going to
make we're going to definitely be making
a little less now. All right. So, right
now, as you guys can see, we have some
stuff selling off. It's all going pretty
decent. Except the toad flex. They keep
dropping and they're not selling at all.
So, it's become a little annoying. I'm
just going to go ahead and throw them in
for I believe
3070 I think is what we're going to go
with. We're just going to let them sit
in there. As far as everything else,
it's all kind of just chilling. Um the
Ranar weeds I could probably stop buying
considering I still have about 1.3,000
left to sell and about another 8 to 900
to end up cleaning. So, uh, for the time
being, I'm going to go ahead and switch
on over to some other stuff. Maybe check
out some Ranar seeds. I don't think I
ever ended up finishing off those. So,
uh, yeah. There we go. So, the quorums
ended up selling off, which is good.
Been waiting for that to happen. A lot
of the Snapdragon seeds was sold. And
other than that, we have kind of a lot
of stuff just chilling. Um, not a whole
lot of the slots are being used, so I'm
going to have to fill up those. And, uh,
as for the RAR seeds, good 500 GP margin
there or 550. So, going ahead and try to
utilize that. All right, so we are
closing in on the end. As you guys can
see, I have some stuff selling off in
here right now. Um, but yeah, right now
I'm just cleaning off all my herbs. So,
you know, making the most of the time, I
guess. All right, so there we go. 55
seconds left. As you guys can see, I'm
I'm being legit. I'm being legit with
this because I had 10 rhinars in the
bank. I made sure to check beforehand.
Going to go ahead and sell all of them
off. And then I also need to check out
and see how much cash to bring out. So,
51642. And there we go. All right. So,
going to go ahead and I believe right
now go and see what I can sell off all
these Rainar weeds for. As you guys can
already see, we have a ton of Rainar
weeds sold off here. I do have to sell
off a ton of these Rainar seeds, which
is good that I'm getting them for 24k
because I think, as I saw earlier, I
could sell them off for about a 500 GP
profit. So, I'll definitely take that if
I can get it, but I'm kind of getting
dumped with them right now. So, I'm
going to take that out right now. So,
I'm going to go ahead and see what I can
sell these off for and then kind of just
clear out everything I got going. All
right. So, as you guys can see, I sold
off all my Snapdragons, which is really
nice. I'm going to take out this timer
just so I mean, you know, you guys
aren't confused. I did end up buying a
lot of a lot more Toad Flax, I guess.
Did more even buy after I just did that.
All right, so I'm going to take out this
offer since the time's up, but uh yeah,
there we go. So, sell still selling off
these torsils. Those land dimes I will
now take out. I only ended up getting
50, so not a whole lot there. And the
torsal seeds I was able to buy a couple
before running out. So, going to go
ahead and sell off everything I have in
my inventory and uh we'll be back here
soon. I doubt it'll take that long to
sell because the tote flags sell pretty
quick. Same with the ranards. The only
thing is maybe the ran our seeds. I
don't think they'll take that long
though either. All right. So, a huge
profit that I didn't even know we might
be making right now. So, I ended up
buying all these torsal seeds as you
guys can see here for 30.1k each. And I
just bought one. I guess I'll show it up
here since that'll be better. And bought
it for that. So that's almost a 5k
profit on what is 44 of them, which
would be 220k. So that would be insane
if they all sell off of that. I don't
know if they will. So I'll have to come
back in like, you know, 10 minutes and
see if any have sold and uh kind of see
what I'm looking at here. All right, so
the game has finished and everything is
sold off. I'm going to go ahead and
throw in my pin. And there we go. So I
did have to come back at one point
during the game just to reset prices,
but I mean really the only thing I had
to reset on was Ranards I think at one
point and Toadlex. So, going to go ahead
and collect it. This kind of the moment
of truth. So, uh let's see how much cash
we're going to get. Boom. Do we hit 100
1 mil? We do. That is always lit because
hitting the 1 mil mark within an hour,
kind of within an hour. I mean, I had to
sell them all off, but I mean, that's,
you know, I mean, whatever. But, uh,
hitting the 1 mil mark is huge as it
kind of solidifies the fact that this
was decent. So, now we're going to see
exactly how much we got and 1.1 and
22K. So yeah, we made a mill in 22k,
which is it's good. It's good. I'm
definitely happy with it to make a mill
an hour merching. And I didn't even need
the 100 mil. I probably could have done
it with like 50. And you could probably
do it with more along the lines of 20 to
30 if you actually just flip things like
very often. You can do it with very low
amounts cuz the things the thing is with
like herbs and stuff like that is you
can flip like a hundred at a time. You
don't have to flip 2,000 like I did.
That's the only reason that I was put
into that situation. So uh hope this was
helpful for you guys. Hope you guys
found some some good ideas for merching.
Hopefully I was able to show you guys
that, you know, pretty much anything is
possible when it comes to merching and
uh yeah, you can try out anything and
it's pretty profitable. So, so if you
guys enjoyed the video, make sure to
leave a like. If you guys want to see
more of my videos in the future, as soon
as they go live, hit that sub button. If
you guys want to check out my French
chat and games, it's not really mine,
but I hang out in there 07 Helpers. You
can also PM me. Make sure to uh comment
down below if you guys got any comments
and uh hit up the Twitter in the
description. Nonetheless, hope you guys
have a wonderful day and peace and
Michigan [__] blew it.
[Music]
You are
you for you.
[Music]